Hello,
and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode live.
My name is David Mackay,
also known as Rawkode across the Internet.
Today, I am very happy to be joined
by
a cloud native ambassador and advocate for the
Cloud Native Computing Foundation.
Hello, Ihor. How are you?
I did. Doing great. Thank you for inviting
me. Really excited to be here.
Yeah. It's gonna be it's gonna be really
good. I think this is one of the
most important episodes that I've done today. Like,
normally, it's the hands on and playing with
our technology. But today, we're actually going to
tackle some of the more
meta questions around what is cloud native and
how to adopt cloud native and all of
this stuff that you know, people either read
about online or consume from talks at conferences.
But sometimes it's just nice to sit down
and get really specific and and and help
break down a few of the barriers to
cloud native adoption, which is why I'm so
excited for today's episode. I think it's gonna
be great.
Of course. I'll try it.
With that in mind, what I would suggest
to anyone watching live is that we really
do want participation with today's episode. So if
you have a question that you would like
us to answer and it could be anything
cloud native related, we'll do our best to
tackle that. The way to do that is
use the comment system on YouTube
or you can tweet either of us and
we'll do our best to bring that into
today's episode.
We do have a collection of questions that
either I, Ehore or people from our Discord
community or Twitter have submitted previously. So we're
gonna start with a few of those and
anything that you want us to drill down
onto, please do not be shy. Get those
questions into us.
So
let's start with a little bit of conversation
around you.
You are a developer advocate for the cloud
native computing foundation.
This must make you the foremost
authoritative answer on what is cloud native. Would
you would you agree with that?
Yeah.
Yes. So the the question about what is
cloud native is probably
the most one of the most simplest and
the one most complicated questions in the technology
world. So it may take a few hours
for us to discuss everything in details.
Alright. Well,
we can maybe we'll we'll go over the
let's say, with the abridged version, I think.
So, I mean, is it safe to say
that that your job, your role is to
help
people and promote
cloud native? Is is that what a developer
advocate at the CNCF is is responsible for?
Yeah. So
my job is an intersection between the classic
technical developer relations, like, in development, we'll go
see,
like, trying some new tools, working with the
developer communities, working with the technical communities,
writing some blog blog posts,
trying demos, and so on, and promoting
promoting technologies
across the across the technology world.
And at the same time, I'm also deeply
involved into the various program management aspects
and community management aspects of the cloud native
community. So we have some unique specifics of
of our organization. So cloud native computing foundation
is not regular.
Let's say, vendor or product company, we are
the
independent nonprofit foundation,
which is hosting various technologies under our umbrella.
And we're mostly we're mostly interested
in spreading the world around these technologies,
but not not adding some, you know, like,
some commercial focus to these technologies and so
on. So
my average job, it can be a bit
more different than the average
than the average day job, the average responsibilities
with the typical development we get from the
from the product company. At the same time,
we are all doing the same job. We're
promoting these technologies. We are connecting the bridges
between the technical
technical communities between the developers' communities and those
people who are trying to consume these technologies
are making decisions about implementation of these technologies
there in their ecosystems.
Awesome. Really cool. I mean, you get to,
you know, on one hand a play with
all of these technologies on a regular basis,
but b, you're also very closely connected to
the community through those initiatives that you just
mentioned. So you also get really good first
and second hand discourse with people that are
either adopting cloud native or already have adopted
cloud native. What I wanted and we're we're
gonna get all of that knowledge out of
your brain today and transmit that to everybody
that's watching on YouTube. So
oh, we have our first. Hello. Hello, John.
Thank you for tuning in. So
let's just try and see if we can
not spend a few hours, but maybe a
few minutes just covering
what is cloud native. If we had to
sum it up in
in a thirty second blurb, what do you
think the most important parts, components, concepts, etcetera
are of CloudNative?
The most important components of CloudNative
is an ability to bundle the different things
into some
shippable and easily distributable units.
They typically call this containers,
but it's
like, being containerized is not absolutely necessary to
be to be to be cloud native.
At the same time, the the way to
implement your technologies,
like, we are exposing the APIs and
using some sort of mesh technologies
or
adapting adapting your tools to be easily deployed
on the different public or private clouds on
premises is the other essential parts of the
the cloud native world.
CNCF has its own
specific definition of what cloud native is. You
can find it under the
CNCF
repo on GitHub under CNCF two zero c
repo on GitHub. So you can find this
brief definition there.
On the various language, it's not only in
English, so I can share the link later.
And, probably, you did, it can share the
link later with with all the subscribers here.
But in general, again,
the cloud native technology is the technology can
that can be
easily used and easily packaged and easily distributed
across where platforms be platform agnostic and can
be easily
distributed across the across
I
don't know if that's my connection.
If anyone can still hear me, if you
can let me know, that would be grand.
Or if we have potentially just lost Ehar.
I'll wait for a thumbs up from somebody.
Otherwise, I'm going to the pub.
Oh, Ehar, are you back? I'm back. Yeah.
Sorry. I had some connectivity issues.
For some reason, they're happening exactly that time
when I went back to it to live.
Sorry. You seem to be perfectly great now.
So we'll just put that down as a
wee blurb, and we'll see what happens.
Alright.
Okay. So I think you you kinda covered
what cloud native was there. The the thing
that struck me right away was you
kinda you said that you don't need containers
to be cloud native.
You don't necessarily need containers. However,
in, like, 99%
of
different cases,
containers are essential. So containers is the organic
part of the cloud native world.
And if we'll come back again to the
history of the cloud native computer foundation as
an organization,
our first and second project was Kubernetes, project
that has been developed by Google
originally
to host to host containers
and to manage containers in the various scale
in various cases across the across the even
across the globe.
So the first project even for the foundation
was the container focused project. And most of
our projects in these days, they are also
container centric.
Yeah. I mean, I think just from my
own experience of speaking to people, you know,
you know, at events last year, of course,
not this year, but or even online this
year is that, you know, I think there's
this kind of I don't know if it's
maybe it's a rule or maybe it's some
sort of misconception, but the idea of the
cloud native and Kubernetes are actually entangled to
a certain point. And there's I I I
feel just on the conversation I had that
people don't think you can be cloud native
without Kubernetes. And is that something you you
would say is untrue then?
It's again, it's not it's not truly true
because you can write containers without Kubernetes. You
can be even a cloud native without containers.
However, again, Kubernetes is the essential part of
most of most of the container focused infrastructures
these these days. Most of most of the
container environments these days are powered by Kubernetes
for obvious reasons. Kubernetes has enough benefits of
why you shouldn't use it in in the
various cases.
However,
it's obvious that you shouldn't use the same
technology for all the cases throughout.
Whereas scenarios where Kubernetes is not is not
truly necessary,
can be you you can just use, for
example, Docker as the container runtime and the
basic container of the straight on your local
machine, for example, and so on. So container
containers and Kubernetes
pretty close to each other, but not synonyms.
Yeah. I guess maybe it would make sense
if we kinda try and cover what are
the
what are the main kind of problems that
cloud native can help organizations
solve?
Like, you know, we if we understand what
it is and we understand that maybe you
don't need Kubernetes, then what does cloud native
aim to solve? And then
maybe we'll lead us on to what Kubernetes
helps solve some of those challenges too.
Sure. We can come back to the to
the benefits of using containers themselves, not not
necessarily the
the
cloud native as an abstraction. So you you
can use containers everywhere it states. And one
of the benefits of using containers and packaging
your applications into containers is that you can
use, for example, your your local laptop to
write some application, bundle your call with some
container, do it, like, in a few commands
and then in a few seconds. And is
it the shipment run the same the same
the same application on
on the public cloud or in a private
cloud or in a remote data center that
is located in a few thousand kilometers from
you?
And this is one of the obvious benefits
of using containers.
And, again, being cloud native means that you
can you can use all the benefits that
that that that this extra environments can can
bring to you.
You know, like, there are even various
various cloud providers that are not only offering
their public cloud offerings. When I was speaking
speaking about cloud,
most people
when most people are speaking about cloud, they
are mostly using this term to to describe
some kind of public cloud, example, some well
known some well known infrastructure that is being
run somewhere by some third party vendor. They
don't have any access to the underlying infrastructure.
They don't have any control
to it.
However,
there's a concept of the on premises
infrastructure
or private cloud.
And
if you're using the private cloud, you're basically
using the same bare metal machines as you
can use in your in your regular physical
data center, and private cloud is essentially the
same physical data center.
However, with the with an additional
set of frustrations with the way
with an ability to control the infrastructure using
the API and the declarative way of managing
the things,
You can you can convert and you can
migrate your
your existing legacy workloads and the legacy ways
of using applications and deploying applications into something
different.
If we're speaking even about the hybrid cloud
approach, so you can you can even use
the same the same set of instructions, the
same
set of API rules in some cases where
you can run the same applications on the
private cloud
within your own data center on an in
a public cloud that has been been deployed
somewhere.
And here comes Kubernetes.
So this is this is the answer to
your to your next question that you were
about to ask, Nick. So why Kubernetes is
so
is is really beneficial for various use cases?
The reason is that you can use you
can use the same Kubernetes cluster
or the same way of controlling of controlling
the various Kubernetes clusters because of the Kubernetes
API, which is not changing
even despite the fact that you can you
can use the same Kubernetes cluster
in a in a public
cloud or you can use the different Kubernetes
cluster in a private cloud in your own
data center. But you'll still use Kubernetes,
the same code base of Kubernetes.
This means you will have the same stable
API.
You can simply run it even, you know,
like,
simple Biden commands, for example,
that will provision some applications for Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes is the next level of of
obstruction,
and it doesn't matter which kind of infrastructure
do you have
below the Kubernetes level.
Wherever you can deploy Kubernetes, you can you
can interact with Kubernetes. You shouldn't interact with
the underlying infrastructure directly if you are trying
to deploy manage your applications.
Okay. So
you can still be cloud native if you're
on a public cloud. You can still be
cloud native if if you're on private cloud
or bare metal or or multi cloud or
all these things. These are all cloud native.
You can use Kubernetes if you want or
containers if you want, but you're gonna get
a lot of benefits if you do. One
of them being that you just said there
is Kubernetes gives us an API we can
deploy to containers, give us the ability to
not just distribute the images, but have some
level of idempotency between what we run across
machines.
You know, there's there's already a lot of
layered benefits here that the more you you
know, what's that phrase? The sum of the
whole is greater than the sum of the
parts. Like when you add each of these
bits, you're just building out a more robust
and resilient system.
Would you say that is the goal for
for people that are adopting cloud native? Is
this just to
architect their systems in a way that is
more robust
or more scalable? Is that a core tenant
of of of cloud native?
It's it's one of the benefits, and it
this is this is one one of the
primary reasons why people
at companies
of the different different size and different scale
are implementing these tools and using these tools,
specifically Kubernetes.
Can use Kubernetes on a single node machine
on your local laptop, and you can also
use Kubernetes in your distributed
your distributed various data centers across the globe
with with the scale of the single cluster
of up to 5,000 nodes per cluster.
So
and you'll still use the same Kubernetes. So
this is the benefit. You'll still use the
same tool. You don't need to learn some
get another tool to to to use it
and to
transfer pieces of code there.
Okay then. So let's
let's continue down this path then. So
it's something that is very prominent
with with cloud native architectures and and people
that I speak to that are adopting this
this
methodology of building software is microservices.
And I believe that the CNCF original definition
did say that microservices
were
required to be cloud native. Is is that
still the case, or do you feel that
that's changed a little bit these days?
Yes
and no. So microservices should be there where
where they're required.
The same time, the cases where microservices are
required are almost everywhere.
The most typical
use case for still using some monolithic application
can be migrating this monolithic application
from the like, from some legacy workloads and
inability
to
to easily convert it into the microservice.
So I know that there are even some
customers and some companies that are using Kubernetes
even to
to bundle some things, some applications that have
been developed even,
like, twenty or thirty years ago in the
mainframe era, for example, that they're using Kubernetes.
They're using some kind of language to bundle
that code within
within some abstraction that can be easily consumed
by Kubernetes, and it can be
provisioned in the run of the Kubernetes cluster.
However, if you are if you are developing
and building
the new applications, specifically from scratch these days,
it's
more or less obvious for most cases that
you you may and should use microservices
because it's the most most efficient way of
managing various resources,
especially if we're speaking about the debate about
the
public cloud infrastructure.
For example, if you're not using some bare
metal machines which have kind of limited capacity,
comparing with the with the public cloud where
you can you can basically run anything and
everywhere anywhere,
so Microsoft is the preferred way of front
end applications.
It will be way more
way more resource efficient for you. It will
be way more
efficient in the terms of the life cycle
management of your applications and so. So there
are enough benefits why should you use microservices
these days.
However, as I mentioned before, it's not
you shouldn't use microservices everywhere,
like, in 100
of cases. If you feel that you don't
need microservices,
you probably don't need.
Okay. Let's
let's prod into that a little bit then.
So I think that's definitely a question that
probably most people have is, you know, I'm
starting on your side project.
You know, do I start with microservices
in which is that gonna have an effect
on the velocity that they could ship the
first version? Because they're, you know, there are
whole lot of challenges that come with microservices.
Mean, maybe we could talk about how Kubernetes
solves a few of those. Yep.
Or, you know, for someone starting up a
new state business or a new startup, you
know, building a monolith might just be a
lot quicker for them, but then the technical
debt they accrue as they build that out
is also gonna have all these challenges too.
Like,
what what is the answer? Is there a
single answer?
There is no single answer.
There is no single answer for all use
cases for
all companies,
for all applications,
for even all the types of applications.
There are various applications that can be easily
easily bundled and packaged into into Microsoft's
team. Even even some legacy applications that been
built, like, ten years ago, they can they
can be easily split into the Microsoft's phone
even today when we're speaking about some stateless
applications.
For example, some state of websites and and
so on. So some stuff something like that.
When we are speaking about some something more
complex,
especially when we're speaking about some cases where
where you have to store your data,
like databases
for some
some complex storage solutions,
especially in the African storage solutions. So probably
it's not the best case just to go
ahead and convert your existing applications into the
into the form of microservices.
You can also combine it. So there's no
direct answer. Should you use microservices
all
everywhere in all the cases?
However,
I would strongly encourage people to consider using
microservices.
And if there is a possibility to use
them and if there is a possibility to
be cloud native from from scratch,
from
from from the first steps, this should be
the it can be the preferred way of
fusing things these days.
Okay. So so right away, like, let's let's
try and play this on on both sides
of the fence then. Let's assume you and
I were speaking to a new company and
we're saying, like, microservices are the best way
for you to start this new application.
Now, immediately, to me, the first thing I'd
wanna say is is a tangible benefit is
the microservices should be small enough that they're
really easy to iterate on, build, test, and
deploy.
Are the other advantages then to microservices?
There are enough advantages around microservices.
So you can easily
again, you can easily develop them.
So if you can easily develop the different
components of the microservices microservices of
the microservices architecture just on the single atomic
basis.
The whole complex structure of the microservices application
compared to the monolithic application can be even
more complex because of the of these various
connections between the microservices
between the microsources pieces
and the
different ways and even probably even different language
languages
which are used to try different parts of
this microservices application.
Again, with monolithic application,
it's way easier for you. As I mentioned
before, there is a for some startup, it
can be way easier just to write some
monolithic application just from the scratch. Just try
some some basic things there and
ship it
even in production,
but what about scaling it? What about
migrating and distributing this this application
across
whereas cloud providers, for example?
So let's say you have
you have an analytic application that is being
run on the public cloud provider a,
but you may have some
issues with that cloud provider. You can have
some.
For example, your country can restrict your access
to that to that cloud provider,
like, on the next day, and you have
no access to that. And you
you're trying to migrate the the tool. You're
trying to migrate the the application to the
different place,
but the cloud provider b has no
has no direct way how can you just
click and run the same application
and migrate it from cloud for the data
to cloud provider b
or the different cases? Like, even even if
you have some, for example, billing issues with
your current cloud provider and you're trying to
resolve your issues with the
with the outstanding payments with your previous cloud
provider, but you already have enough credits on
the cloud provider b. So in the in
the microservices world, you can you can easily
move these pieces from cloud provider a to
the cloud provider b
and run them almost seamlessly. With the monolithic
tools,
it can be complicated. It's not necessarily complicated
in in all cases, but monolithic
monolithic application make makes you less flexible.
You are less flexible on also in terms
of development.
So if you if you are trying to
upgrade
some minor piece, but minor but essential piece
of your monolithic application will have to rebuild
the whole application. It will take some time.
It will take some development resources.
It may
it may have even
some compatibility
issues in the future. But if you upgrade
in the small piece of the model, we
take a look of the microservices application, I'm
sorry. If you upgrade in a small piece
of the microservices applications, you're just upgrading the
same that that single piece of that seed.
All the remaining all the remaining parts of
your microsources microsources
structure will remain the same and unchanged,
and we don't don't have to rebuild them
again from scratch and test the complete compatibility
with the new platform and so.
So, again, various cases,
if you're running if you're just running something
like the basic front end application
on a single machine that is located somewhere
and this is the primary business case for
your organization,
you may consider just using that static website
even not containerizing that just running something like
an engine x and that's it.
Yep. At the same time, if you'll run
different pieces of the application like the front
end front
end app, back end apps, some database,
some
as traditional pieces of code that should be
added as the extensions and so on. So
this was considered in a conversion days for
the capture into the microservices
one.
Okay. There I mean, there was a lot
there. There's some really great points I think
that people need to consider when they're they're
they're tasked with this question at their organization.
I mean, I think what I'm taking away
from what you said there is, like,
cloud native should probably be the default, and
you should identify which use cases, which applications
shouldn't be rather than the model if it's
a default and then trying to work out
when to be cloud native. So
the people that are listening to this should
just say,
this is a cloud native application until I
have a reason not to do it. Another
kind of really prominent thing that you were
you came back to a few times there
was just the
fact that the microservices allows you to contain
logic into small sections, small parts that we
can move out, we can replace, we we
can iterate on and the amount of knowledge
you need to be able to do that
is much more minimal than having to understand
like a whole car for instance. You might
just understand the steering wheel, the gearbox, the
clutch, etcetera. And I think that works really
well. So
let me turn the question around a little
bit then. Macro
services and cloud native architectures allow us to
build smaller components that we can understand. Do
we need to move the simplicity from our
app do we need to move complexity from
our applications or is it just pushed away
somewhere?
So fun fact that with
when we're comparing, again, microsources and monolithic
monolithic applications, we're adding extra complexity to to
the microservices
applications.
Because, again, you have to
you have to connect together various pieces of
the
different, like, different pieces of code.
For example, how can you hear how can
you bundle easily? How can you connect these
also piece of code that is written in
pilot, for example, in Go?
It's
almost impossible
in the in in the different in the
different cases, like, with the monolithic applications.
With microservices,
you'll have to add some extra extra level
of instructions just to connect it. In this
case, you'll you'll need you'll
need to have some universal set of set
of APIs within your application
where you can connect these different different pieces
of your applications that are located on a
different
different size of this field, let's call it.
Let's call it this way.
Yes. The minute we we apply this architecture
to our applications, we have a distributed application,
and that brings a whole host of complexity
to it. So whether services are getting simpler,
we're I guess that's all now in the
infrastructure there, which is where Kubernetes comes in
and and saves the day. Would you say
Kubernetes solves
a lot of the complexities or undistributed applications,
and how does it do that?
Again, Kubernetes is an extremely complex tool. So
it will add enough complexity to your general
architecture,
but it will remove
enough
endpoints for you to manage or and to
manage and to use your your whole
your whole level of
of the your whole set of instructions there.
So Kubernetes is an extremely complex tool, but
will simplify your life in some in some
different cases.
Again,
a good sample of
where where and how Kubernetes can be essential
for you, I just mentioned, like, five minutes
ago. So you can have you can run
the same set of applications and control them
from the single control plane, from the single
control point
even if your applications should be should be
provisioned in the private
cloud data center that is located in The
United States
and on a public cloud that is based
somewhere in Japan, for example.
But you can still control the same applications
from the same place, your single control plane,
and you, as an operator,
you'll you'll have to interact only with that
single control plane. Control plane. Everything else will
be handled by Kubernetes.
Excellent.
Let's tackle a viewer question then, which I
think kind of segues nicely right now. So
John McCabe is asking,
what are some of the common or avoidable
missteps or pitfalls when organizations adopt cloud native?
The most
the most common
the most common misstep is that
sometimes people are considering
cloud native as
you know, like, when people are considering that
cloud native can solve all their questions,
but
it doesn't.
And the reason here is that CloudNet is
not a silver bullet.
Kubernetes and containers are not a silver bullet.
You still have to develop your locations and
your
your configuration and and design your architecture in
the most efficient way.
You it's it's a big mistake
to to think that if even if you
develop your
architecture
and your application in in some where way
the next will solve it for you. It's
not the case.
Even even it will be more more difficult
to
to adapt and redesign your application and your
your architecture if you've if you develop this
in in some non efficient way and to
enhance it to be more efficient later.
So
the the
the the basic the basic
probably the basic point here,
you still have to write some good code
and some efficient code to be to be
to be run somewhere, and it doesn't matter
if we would be around containers,
we should buy Kubernetes or just be around
somewhere on the pure bimetal
SDS.
Yeah.
Definitely. I think that, you know, there's a
lot of maturity
with regards to writing software that has to
be kind of
understood and you have to have solved a
lot. You've you've got to understand some of
the problems that cloud native solves before you
can start applying it as a solution for
everything. I think is what's really important. And
that's kinda what I got from what you
were saying like Yeah. If you don't understand
the past problems and you're just applying a
solution that you don't really know what is
solving yet, and that's gonna lead you down
probably a trap, a whole bunch of errors
that otherwise you may have you may be
able to fix. I think I made it
right now. I get it. Okay. Yeah. So
It's something I I've seen a lot.
You know, I go to a lot of
conferences as I'm sure you do as well.
People
are always asking for what is what is
the first step?
And I'm I'm gonna
say what I normally say and then say
that it's also the worst advice that I
always give. And I still give this advice
but I think there's some there's a reason
for that. So when people say what is
the first step, I normally tell them just
containerize your application and and deploy it as
it is. Like, know, just getting
and and when I say that, what I'm
asking them to do is to build a
CI pipeline where they build an image and
run a places which pushes
them down the 12 factor path.
But then it's also the worst advice to
give because people take that container image and
throw Kubernetes. And it's the only service, the
only pod and they're just scaling it on
the architecture using the Kubernetes API.
And I think that's also has a huge
detrimental effect on them because they did again,
they don't understand the problems that Kubernetes is
solving with with networking and service discovery and
health checks and all this stuff because they're
not necessarily using those components.
So I'm curious.
I give a bad advice, it sounds, but
I'm hopefully trying to help people. What do
you think is, like, a good first step
for people that wanna adopt Cooper adopt cloud
native coming from maybe a monolithic background?
My first my advice about the first step
would be learn your own code.
Know what you are writing,
know what you are building, know what are
deploying.
If you if you don't know what what
you're using, you don't know what you're trying
to adopt
for the cloud native for the cloud native
infrastructure,
you there is a high chance that you'll
have some issues with with
the immediate adoption or you you may have
some issues later during the adoption cycle.
Learn what you want what you're doing,
and
the second the second first step is learn
that that technologies that you're planning to use.
Learn Kubernetes.
Play with Kubernetes. Play with Kubernetes, deploy on
each on your local machine, your local laptop,
for example.
Try to run some some basic applications, understand
what kind of potential even potential issues and
potential complexity that can Kubernetes
and to the application and that Kubernetes can
add to the environment.
Good case,
you may have the,
like, the tiny
tiny machine somewhere in a public cloud, you
know, data, etcetera. Whereas cloud providers that are
offering, like, something like the micro micro VM
or tiny VM or something like that, and
their public public cloud offerings,
typically, is a part of the free tier
where you can you you may receive
you may receive something like
megabytes of the of of RAM,
something like one virtual CPE, which is shared
across
across the whole
across the whole rack where this this machine
is this virtual machine is deployed. So sometimes
people are trying to use this this tiny
tiny VM, tiny machine to run Kubernetes and
run some applications within it. But
the typical Kubernetes cluster
these days might require around one one gigabyte
of RAM just to just run itself it
it it itself. So
you can run even Kubernetes itself without any
without any workloads on that machine.
But you can easily run your
your small single goal and based application there,
for example.
So, again, learn your code and learn your
tools that you're trying to use.
As much as as much as difficult to
run Kubernetes cluster on a 500
megabytes RAM machine,
the same in absolutely the same way, it's
terribly difficult to run some simple simple application
in a
highly highly distributed, highly scaled environment
on a few thousand nodes without any kind
of orchestration, without any kind of containerized solutions
like Kubernetes.
Okay. Awesome.
So
let's go back to something that you you
mentioned earlier. You when you were talking about
microservices,
you talked about databases.
Now we did have a a viewer submit
a question before we started, and their their
question was, do I really need a database
per service?
This sounds like an awful lot of work.
So do you have any thoughts or opinions
that or even advice to people that are
not sure how to structure their their stateful
services and databases and back end stores, etcetera?
Yeah. Again, it depends it depends on the
use cases
the use cases of your application
and the use cases for your databases.
The most typical way
especially the early days of Kubernetes that I've
I've been following, and I've I've noticed that
multiple companies and even multiple enterprises
have been using this that use can try
services in the cloud native the cloud native
technologies and the cloud native architecture
for the stateful
for the stateless services.
But for the stateful workloads,
you use some dedicated
use some dedicated database cluster that you that
is just plugged into your
Kubernetes cluster, for example.
So your database should not be necessarily
should not be necessarily containerized,
and it should not necessarily be being run
within within the Kubernetes cluster, for example.
But you can still use all the benefits
of using devs k full services with Kubernetes.
But, again, there are so many various cases
where you should use even databases with Kubernetes
and try enough cases where you shouldn't do
it.
Yeah. I I think I I think this
is a hot topic and a about
should I run staple workloads in in Kubernetes?
Yeah. I'm firmly on the yes. I think
we should be running a database using Kubernetes.
I think if we look at the benefits,
you know, of health checks, reconciliation,
as as long as you can solve the
storage
problem, you know, and we can talk about
CSI drivers. Not
something I'm particularly knowledgeable about, so maybe I'll
avoid that as as much as I can.
I think, you know, there's a lot of
benefits to having a stateful workloads in Kubernetes
and been able to plan and plan for
failures, know, like it's things aren't gonna go
wrong, but then we learn how to fix
them whereas
I don't know. I that the concept that
I've got a Kubernetes cluster, sorry I'm ranting
now. Got a Kubernetes cluster and I'm running
my state for workloads on VM somewhere else
that could still have the same problems they
would inside a container environment. I mean,
like, in fact, here's a question. Sorry. I'm
Of course. Going off on one.
I always tell people there's no difference from
running a database in Kubernetes using a host
path mount and fixing it to a node.
So there is just running that process on
a node. I mean, is that something you
would agree with or something that you you
think I should stop saying?
I
can't I can't respond immediately.
We have to we have to follow-up on
that.
So
as as you I'm not sure about the
about the correctness of this statement. So let's
let's skip this and discuss later.
No problem. I'll I'll maybe just run a
bit on Twitter at some point and have
the Internet tell me why I'm wrong. But
I Good good good good point for the
Twitter for the Twitter poll. Right?
Okay. Let's say I jump back to a
few of your questions then. So we
had a few questions that were essentially along
lines of do I need x in order
to be cognitive?
One of them was CICD.
One of them was good monitoring.
You know, are there any prerequisites
that people need to be
good with before they could be cloud native?
Or, I mean, is this just good code
hygiene in general? Like, people probably should have
CI and CD regardless of being cloud native.
What are your thoughts on that?
I agree I agree with your point on
on
call hygiene.
I agree with your with your points that
with your point that CI, CD tools are
mostly essential in the most in the most
complex environments these days.
Even if you're not using Kubernetes, for example,
or if you're not using the contrast clusters,
if you are running and if you're releasing
your applications
into it, if you're developing your applications frequently,
if you're releasing new pieces of code regularly,
you have to use the CI and CD
tools to
to
to deliver them properly.
So it's it's an unrelated
it's it's a related but unrelated topic to
to the cloud native world and to the
to the cloud native cloud native architecture markets.
It's a good practice to use CICD tools
with the complex environments.
It's not truly necessary in some cases. Again,
if you just
if you have just released your
your single version of your application and you
don't expect to release any any version of
your application in the over over single future.
So, again, CICD tools can x
CICD tools can add extra complexity to
to your code base and to your infrastructure.
But if you are releasing your your applications
frequently,
if you are releasing some updates frequently, so
you have deployed some patches there,
so you should use these tools.
Again, not necessarily with Kubernetes exactly and not
not only with Kubernetes clusters, but it's just
like
it's just a a good practice for everyone
who is doing this.
Alright. So,
yes, you should have CICD. Yes. You should
have good monitoring.
It's not necessarily a prerequisite to to call
the cloud native architecture. Exactly. Yes. Exactly. So
it's not a definition of cloud native to
use CICD.
Yeah. And it's not the definition of the
cloud native application,
but in the in theory. Right? But in
the practical world, not in most of the
use cases you should use, you you you
should have some good monitoring tool. You should
have some CICD
tools that will be embedded into your
into your architecture. It should be the organic
parts of your architecture.
I think I
think we've kind of also answered the final
viewer question there as well with with our
kind of answer there. The final question was,
you know, does Cloud Native complement or compete
with methodologies like agile and DevOps? And I
think the same answer applies here is that
you just should have all these good practices
in place regardless of being Cloud Native or
not. And then cloud native is just gonna
hopefully enrich those processes that you've already built
through good engineering, I guess. Yep. Yep. The
term DevOps or agile,
they've been they've been emerged way before cloud
native definition has emerged. But today
today, they're typically used in the same sentence.
Again, they're not sign in names. They're not
meaning the same,
but they are complementary
and
with with the cloud native technologies, you can
you can boost your
you can use your you can boost your
DevOps DevOps partners in a way more efficient
way that you can do before, like, ten
years ago, for example, when how many was
noticing.
Excellent. Cool. I think we've answered a lot
of of of really good questions there.
Awesome.
So is there Good news.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. No. It's like
it's such a I think there's a lot
of misconception. I think there's a lot of
ambiguity. I think people
you see so much, you know, on Twitter
and through articles about cloud native, about Kubernetes,
about all these tools. Of course, you know,
KubeCon and the CloudNativeCons are just such massive
events. So there's a lot of buzz and
a lot of I guess for the people
that haven't gone down this path yet, maybe
a lot of fear as well. It's quite
intimidating and, know, hopefully just taking a few
of these questions and giving people a little
bit of confidence and insight into what they
need to do this is really gonna help.
So thank you very much for joining me
today.
Thank you for inviting me. If you have
any final thoughts, you may drop them now.
Otherwise, again, thank you very much. It has
been an absolute pleasure.
Of course. Thank you for inviting me, and
glad to be here.
Alright. Well, thank you. You have a great
day, and I I will speak to you
soon. Adios. Sure.